Ce fut presque deux ans plus tard
que j'ai compris comment on devrait appeler cette personne.
J'étais en train de parler à l'Université du Michigan
aux candidats du MBA,
en parlant des leçons que j'avais apprises
après mes 3 petites années à Wall Street,
et ça m'a frappée.
Je dis : « Oh, cette personne qui défend tes intérêts,
ou comme j'aime bien dire, qui te présente dans la salle,
cette personne qui investit
son précieux capital politique et social sur toi,
cette personne qui va taper du poing sur la table pour toi,
c'est un sponsor !
C'est un sponsor. »
Donc je me suis dit :
« Ok, comment on trouve un sponsor ?
Et franchement, pourquoi en a-t-on besoin ? »
Eh bien, on a besoin d'un sponsor,
parce que comme on peut le voir,
il n'y a aucun processus d'évaluation qui me vient à l'esprit,
que ce soit à l'université, en soins de santé, en finances,
aucun qui n'a pas l'élément humain.
Cela signifie qu'il y a toujours ce degré de subjectivité.
Il y a un degré de subjectivité en la personne qui présente votre cas.
Il y a un degré de subjectivité
dans ce qu'il dit
et dans la manière d’interpréter chaque donnée objective.
Il y a un degré de subjectivité dans ce qu'il dit, dans ce qu'il va dire
pour influencer le résultat.
Donc, il faut être sûr que cette personne qui parlera pour vous,
ce sponsor,
a vos plus grands intérêts à cœur
et a le pouvoir de les obtenir, quelle que soit la valeur pour vous,
de les obtenir à huis-clos.
Or, on me demande toujours :
« Comment en trouver un ? »
Honnêtement, le nirvana, c'est quand quelqu'un te voit dans un environnement
et décide : «Je vais faire en sorte que cela se produise pour toi.
Je vais m'assurer que tu aies du succès. »
Mais pour la majorité de nous ici, on sait que cela ne se passe pas comme ça.
Alors laissez-moi introduire ce concept de devise
et vous expliquer comment cela influe votre capacité d'obtenir un sponsor.
Il y a existe deux types de devises quel que soit l'environnement :
la devise de la performance et la devise des relations.
La devise de la performance est la devise générée
par votre capacité à délivrer ce qui vous est demandé
et même un peu plus.
Chaque fois que vous exécutez une tâche au-delà des attentes des gens,
vous créez de la devise de performance.
Ça fonctionne exactement comme le marché boursier.
Chaque fois qu'une entreprise crie sur les toits
qu'ils vont livrer 25 centimes par action
et que l'entreprise livre 40 centimes par action,
sa valeur boursière monte, et vous aussi.
La performance est précieuse pour trois raisons.
Un, ça vous fera remarquer.
Ça vous crée une réputation.
Deux, ça vous permettra d'être payé et promu
très tôt dans votre carrière
et très tôt dans n'importe quel domaine.
Trois, elle attire un sponsor.
Pourquoi ? Parce qu'une devise de performance haute
augmente votre niveau de visibilité dans l'environnement,
de façon à ce qu'un sponsor puisse être attiré par vous.
Pourquoi ? Parce que tout le monde aime une star.
Mais si vous vous retrouvez dans une situation
où vous n'avez pas de sponsor,
voilà la bonne nouvelle.
Rappelez-vous que vous pouvez exercer votre pouvoir et en demander un.
Mais maintenant voici où l'autre devise est plus importante.
C'est la devise des relations,
et la devise des relations est générée
par l'investissement que vous mettez dans les personnes de votre milieu,
l'investissement que vous mettez dans les personnes de votre milieu.
Vous ne pouvez pas demander à quelqu'un d'utiliser
son influence personnelle durement gagnée en votre nom
si vous n'avez jamais eu d'interaction avec.
Ça n'arrivera pas.
Donc c'est important d'investir votre temps pour rencontrer, pour interagir
et pour apprendre à connaître les gens dans votre environnement,
et encore plus important pour leur donner l'opportunité de vous connaître.
Parce qu'une fois qu'ils vous connaissent,
il y a une plus grande probabilité que quand vous les approcherez
pour leur demander d'être votre sponsor,
ils vous répondront oui.
Or, si vous êtes d'accord avec moi sur le fait qu'il faut avoir un sponsor,
parlons de comment l'identifier.
Eh bien, si vous cherchez un sponsor,
il doit avoir trois caractéristiques principales.
Un, il doit avoir une place à la table décisionnelle,
il doit être visible à votre travail
pour avoir crédibilité à huis-clos,
et il doit être reconnu,
ou, laissez-moi le dire autrement, il doit avoir du pouvoir.
C'est très important qu'il ait ces trois choses.
Et une fois que vous avez identifié cette personne,
comment lui demander ?
Le script est :
« Jim, je suis vraiment intéressé par une promotion cette année.
J'ai eu une année magnifique
et je ne peux rien montrer de plus pour prouver ma valeur
ou ma capacité à cette promotion,
mais je sais que quelqu'un doit être présent
pour argumenter en ma faveur et frapper sur la table.
Tu me connais, tu connais mon travail et tu as vu les retours des clients,
et j'espère que tu pourras argumenter en mon nom. »
Si Jim te connais
et vous avez une sorte de relation,
il y a une probabilité très élevée qu'il dise oui,
et s'il dit oui,
il s'efforcera de le faire pour vous.
Mais il y a aussi une probabilité que Jim dise non,
et s'il dit non, à mon avis,
il y a seulement trois raisons possibles.
La première, c'est qu'il ne pense pas connaître assez votre travail
pour avoir une vraie crédibilité
et être percutant et efficace en votre nom.
La deuxième raison qui pourrait lui faire dire non
c'est que vous pensez qu'il a l'influence pour le faire,
mais il sait qu'il n'a pas le pouvoir de le faire
et il ne vous l'avouera pas pendant votre conversation.
(Rires)
Et la troisième raison qui pourrait lui faire dire non,
c'est qu'il ne vous aime pas.
Il ne vous aime pas.
(Rires)
Et c'est quelque chose qui peut arriver.
Mais ce sera quand même une information précieuse
qui vous aidera pour votre prochaine interaction avec un sponsor
et qui pourrait la rendre un peu plus percutante.
Je ne sais comment vous dire combien c'est important d'avoir un sponsor.
C'est la relation clé de votre carrière.
Un mentor, franchement, c'est chouette à avoir,
mais dans votre carrière, on peut survivre longtemps sans un mentor,
mais vous ne monterez dans aucune entreprise sans un sponsor.
C'est vraiment important que vous vous demandiez régulièrement :
« Qui défendra ma cause dans cette salle-là ? »
Et si vous ne savez pas y répondre,
alors je vais vous dire de détourner une part de votre énergie
et de l'investir dans une relation avec un sponsor,
parce que c'est capital pour votre succès.
Et pour finir, laissez-moi dire un mot
aux futurs sponsors qui sont dans cette salle.
Si vous êtes invité dans la pièce,
sachez que vous avez une place à cette table,
et si vous avez une place à cette table,
vous avez la responsabilité de parler.
Ne gâchez pas votre pouvoir en vous inquiétant de ce que les gens vont dire
et s'ils pensent ou non que vous pourriez soutenir quelqu'un
juste parce qu'il vous ressemble.
Si quelqu'un est digne de votre devise,
dépensez-la.
Une chose que j'ai apprise après quelques décennies à Wall Street,
c'est que la manière de développer votre pouvoir, c'est de le donner,
et votre voix est au cœur de cela.
(Applaudissements)
Et votre voix est au cœur de votre pouvoir.
Utilisez-la.
Merci beaucoup.
(Applaudissements)